olibeau et puis bah je souhaite un bon
dimanche profiter de votre journée tout
au long de la matinée les cyclistes ont
afflué vers le quartier des deux lions
où était installé le village départ de
ce vélo tenir en famille entre amis de
tous âges et déguisés pour beaucoup la
bonne humeur autre cas est de mise en
ouvre des lieux en fait spécialement
pour l'événement c'est à dire que par
exemple si je vais à la faculté de
médecine j'ai passé des moments puis
j'ai pas pouvoir rentrer avec un vélo là
aujourd'hui je vais à la faculté de
médecine
je rends dans l'amphithéâtre j'ai pas un
legrand pareil pour le parc des
expositions pour éviter que le parcours
ne deviennent impraticables les départs
sont échelonnés et en fin de matinée les
derniers partants croise déjà les
premiers arrivés à l'issue d'une boucle
de 17 km ou même 20 pour les plus
curieux
on a bien déliré les gens un peu
halluciné en voyant déguisé après les
envolées sur le speedway bien sympa
comme
comme petit randonneurs au départ des
deux lions la balade commence par une
traversée des jardins familiaux
puis de lille balzac sur le cher pour
arriver dans l'antre du tfc le stade de
la vallée du cher où beaucoup de
participants choisissent de mettre un
pied à terre une première fois comme le
cette bande d'amis haute en couleurs on
s'est dit ça serait sympa un matin de
pouvoir découvrir des endroits insolites
de la ville
autre nom et pouvoir partager un moment
ensemble convivial avec les familles et
déguisés en plus à suivre les virages
relevés de la piste de speedway où de
nombreux cyclistes se sentent pousser
des ailes
au total 17 sites où les vélos ne sont
pas forcément les bienvenus en général
pourront ainsi être découverts au fil de
la boucle